und wieder
die audio
new york
die joh
andreas gabalier hat den schlager rock
geprägt und längst allen in der größe
wie sie auch elena fischer oder robbie
williams bespielen ein megastar den wir
aber jetzt erst mal nicht mehr auf der
bühne sehen werden zumindest nicht in
österreich denn unsere nachbarn sind
seit heute wieder im komplett lockdown
und jetzt ist er uns aber auch
zugeschaltet andreas gabalier guten
abend ja hallo hallo ich bin extra
geflüchteten das schöne hamburg
verzeichnet heute eine tv show aus hier
und in diesem blog dann in österreich
schon ganz schnell im flur ja in
deutschland kann man sich ja noch etwas
freier bewegen aber trotzdem die erste
frage auch an sie die man ja
mittlerweile fast jeder person stellt
sind sie selber geimpft ja ja schon
relativ lange es war sobald die impfung
für mich eigentlich gegeben hat ich
glaube es war im juni ja trotzdem das
ist auch gar nicht anders möglich für
mich irgendwie gewesen sie haben so
viele wege so viele tv shows als wäre
ein ding der unmöglichkeit ganz nebenbei
ja gar nicht trotzdem gilt jetzt auch
für sie seit heute in österreich wieder
ein loch da und genauso wie für
ungeimpfte auf wen sehen sie mehr sauer
auf die politik die zu früh alle
freiheiten zurückgegeben hat oder auf
die ungeimpften und impfverweigerer die
zur verschärfung dieser situation
beigetragen haben
es ist so schwer da irgendwie fehlen
werden das größte problem dass ich mit
dieser ganzen bande eigentlich habe ist
dass es die leute so dermaßen spaltet
und das ist eigentlich ein sehr
trauriger beigeschmack an dieser krise
sei
in all meinen lebenslagen und
situationen immer versucht irgendwie das
leben so zu nehmen wie es ist und wie es
kommt und irgendwie das beste daraus zu
machen für uns künstler natürlich eine
besonders harte situation weil wir auch
wirklich seit zwei jahren nicht mehr auf
der bühne waren wir haben meine
anstehenden sommerkonzerte wieder auf
das nächste jahr verschoben also ich bin
guter dinge dass wir wiederkommen das
wieder zurückgekommen aber es wird noch
ein paar monate dauern sie haben es
gerade schon angesprochen das land ist
im moment gestalten bzw die bürger sind
gespalten in wien hat es ja auch extreme
juden gegeben in belgien und in den
niederlanden kam es auch zu gewalt
glauben sie dass so was in österreich
auch passieren kann
ich hoffe nicht ich hoffe doch dass das
irgendwie weiterhin friedliche
demonstrationen sind und bleiben werden
will muss man die leute auch verstehen
dass hier nun mut da zum ausdruck
bringen versucht und in allen lagen
hinein zu versetzen weil das natürlich
für ganz ganz viele leute
oft einfach ausnahmezustand heißt und
weil mittlerweile hat auch ganz ganz
viele firmen freunde von mir die große
unternehmen haben vor auch massiv
betroffen sind von diesen ganzen
finanziellen einbußen man musste erstmal
über die runden kommen die leute sind
natürlich die spalten auch in ihrem
denken was jetzt diese impfpflicht oder
diese angesprochenen impfpflicht
irgendwie angeht und kann man hoffen
dass das weiterhin so friedlich über die
bühne geht auch der polizei gegenüber
das ist auch so ein punkt wo ich diese
bilder gesehen habe speziell aus dem
ausland sei immer da tun wir die
polizisten dann schon auch irgendwo leid
wenn auf einmal dass er gewalt aufkommt
und
es ist eine große aufgabe von uns allen
irgendwie da ein halbwegs ein halbwegs
harmonisches miteinander
weiterhin auch an den tag zu legen ich
war es geht nur miteinander das ist es
ist leider einfach nicht es ist so nicht
leider sondern es ist so nicht nennen
nur schauen dass wir alle miteinander
auskommen und das wird natürlich auch
mit dieser steigenden weltbevölkerung
dichte immer und immer schwieriger
ressourcen technisch klimatechnisch und
und runter das klappt dann muss er
bisher bis auf sich schauen auf uns
schauen wie wir sie haben es
angesprochen stichwort impfpflicht bei
uns in deutschland wird darüber
diskutiert in österreich wird als erstes
eu-land ab februar die impfpflicht
eingeführt was halten sie davon eine
pflicht zu nehmen
bei mir ist es immer so richtig egal was
ich sage ist immer ganz ganz großer
zündstoff und
ich bin selber geimpft ob es die lösung
ist oder nicht weiß ich nicht wird man
sehen
richten sind natürlich dann immer
verbunden auch mit mit emotionalen
ausspielungen irgendwie die menschheit
lässt sich nicht gerne zu irgendwas hin
hin verwässern oder hin donnern
schwierig keine frage es gibt gott sei
dank ganz ganz ganz ganz viele politiker
und medien die oft ihre dazu beitragen
und meinungen dazu haben da freu' mich
in den letzten monaten ein bisschen
bisschen zurückgenommen weil ich weiß
was das heißt wenn ich was sage und in
erster linie sage ich mal so bin ich
eigentlich
entertainment und unterhaltung trotzdem
ärger wäre trotzdem sie sind eine großes
vorbild wir haben millionen instanz wenn
sie etwas sagen dann hat es auch eine
große bedeutung sie könnten ja
beispielsweise zum impfen auf rufen
statt sich rauszuhalten ja das habe ich
glaube ich auch in den letzten wochen
und monaten schon das ein oder andere
mal gesagt ich habe mich impfen lassen
weil es bei mir gar nicht anders möglich
ist auch am anfang auch bisher darüber
nachgedacht man sieht was im ländern los
ist wo die im frisch und weit höher ist
als in österreich das heißt gleiche
system lösung ob es wirklich die lösung
ist oder nicht kann ich nicht sagen wir
impfen lassen und das
weiß ich nicht ob es aktiv ob diese
pflicht da jetzt wirklich
ich hoffe dass es weiterhin friedlich
zugeht und dass die leute das mit
vernunft annehmen daher gab er welche
dinge mussten sie dennoch privat absagen
gab es da irgendwas was jetzt den
lockdown betrifft den österreich in dem
sich österreich jetzt gerade befindet
gab es da etwas was sie auch privat
getroffen hat
nein ich habe gestern geburtstag gehabt
das heißt wir haben noch ein herrliches
terrassen bier getrunken in meiner stern
den steirischen landeshauptstadt graz im
süden österreichs mit alten freunden
und ab heute ist alles dicht ich bin
schnell geflohen nach hamburg wir
zeichnen wie gesagt eine chance auf
morgen in erfurt
also ich bin beruflich an der wette
gegen sie unterwegs momentan hat leider
nicht auf den großen live bühnen aber im
4 sind sind doch einige anfragen jetzt
wir haben unsere weihnachtsplatte vom
feuer relaunchs das heißt sie kommt auch
so mit kleinen weihnachtsfilm und als
vinyl ausgabe wir arbeiten an den shows
für das nächste jahr da bin ich bester
dinge dass das im sommer stattfinden
wird wenn nicht den vergangenen sommer
her nehmen und da diese fußballspiele in
diesen größen dimensionen oder auch
andere große konzerte im ausland
mitverfolgt habe
dann glaube ich daran dass wir nächstes
jahr spielen werden wir haben auch
bereits die ersten zusatzkonzerte für
diese nachholkonzert in den vorverkauf
geschickt von berlin über
mönchengladbach bis hinunter nach
südtirol
erstmal noch mal herzlichen glückwunsch
nachträglich perfektes timing natürlich
ein tag vom ahorn den geburtstag zu
feiern letzte frage kennen sie
eigentlich florian andreas der mann sind
ihnen wie aus dem
sein doppelgänger sieht
schwer zu sagen die schwer zu sagen es
ist nicht nur einer ich glaube es laufen
sieben oder acht zu
rock'n'roller imitator herum ich habe
ihn einmal glaube kennengelernt am wert
dass sie durch zufall in dieser bar wo
ich vor meiner musikalischen laufbahn
als schüler und student immer gerne
gehabt habe in den sommermonaten und da
hat da nicht irgendwann einmal abgepasst
und da haben wir ein foto gemacht dass
darüber haben sich die historischen
zeitungen schon vor einem jahr gefreut
und jetzt hier auch immer mehr im
ausland lebt gehört in düsseldorf gibt
auch einen ähnlichen volks rock'n'roller
verschnitt der dort auch geklappt bis zu
200 auftritte im jahr gemacht hat nimmt
einer kleinen diskothek also schon ganz
verrückt die irgendwie ja
wir werden ihn gleich fragen was er da
von ganz herzlichen dank für das
gespräch und genießen sie die zeit im
exil in hamburg danke herr gabriel
ist alles liebe
bevor wir zu dem gespräch mit dem
doppelgänger von andreas gabalier kommen
schauen wir ihn uns doch einmal im
direkten vergleich an
[Musik]
das
limburg
das team ist
und jetzt sprechen wir mit ihm florian
andreas nicht andreas gabalier volks
rock'n'roller verschnitt andreas
gabalier gesagt das passt ja zu ihrem
eigentlichen beruf als holz lkw-fahrer
in tirol weil es ihnen die ähnlichkeit
zum ersten mal aufgefallen christ und
halli hallo ausdruck deutschland und ein
kessel ist danke schön dass wir dabei
sind fx und freude für mich und die
messung die ähnlichkeit hat eigentlich
ganz frischen anfangen also in den
jugendjahren haben wir die leute immer
wieder auch die ähnlichkeit angesprochen
und darum eigentlich gar nicht so viel
mir dabei geht es dabei sich im laufe
der jahre natürlich mit dem ersten foto
muss man miteinander es gemacht haben
immer wieder weitergeben und javi varas
war wieso schneeballsystem es war wartet
noch ein ander nun dass sich natürlich
ein riesen freude für mich und die
kinder wirklich mit herzblut und mit
sehr sehr viel energie und ausdauer
dabei und es macht noch spaß erzählte
glass wahrheit sehen damals zum ersten
mal getroffen haben
das erste treffen eigentlich bei uns in
austin das hosting zealand obama
wirklich kaffee trinkt noch sein konzert
im max und das haben wir mit netto
vorbeifahren und dann immer wieder
schallten über den schon mal irgendwo
erkennen und noch einmal gemüse und mit
dem ca foto jochen gehen und das waren
eigentlich der startschuss für eine
musikalische karriere also genau dem tod
kann ich mein bruder kurven war der
modekette c&a monika lernen nicht so
kovats ist in der musikszene wirklich
nie tun blickt bewundert sondern das war
auch der druck immer weiter da haben wir
gerade schon mal angesprochen sie haben
ja andreas gaber hier eben selbst schon
mal getroffen was war denn insgesamt
bisher ihr schönstes verwechslung
ereignis gab es da auch schon mal was
sie auf der straße zum beispiel
angesprochen wurden was passiert
eigentlich immer wieder als es sich beim
einkaufen oder bei zelt fürchte es wird
immer wieder
verwechslungen geben und das blatt die
herren die unter wirklich große freude
wenn die leute zu mir käme und
autogrammkarten bilden und fotos machen
äußeres ich wirklich wo wir es bis jetzt
natürlich aufgeht und dass man freude
bereitet ja wir haben mit herrn gab es
ja bereits auch über die korona
situation gesprochen in österreich ist
jetzt ein locker und verhängt worden
haben sie denn davon jetzt auch schon
etwas mitbekommen beziehungsweise waren
sie davon auch direkt schon getroffen ja
natürlich ich bin da direkt betroffen
war und dessen das für mich natürlich
sehr für die auftritte weg sollen in
dancing netzteile zum beispiel erzählt
sehr viele weihnachtsfeiern gewesen
wären aber natürlich leider gottes ist
das leider alles in sack voll normaal
muss natürlich und vorderster front
ständig die gesundheit und das kam mir
so leid meine gefährden und darf man
nicht gefährden und dass menschen wieder
bessere zeiten kommen da diese ja vielen
dank dann erstmal für das gespräch alles
gute weiteren halten sie durch jetzt
während dieses lockt da uns in der
korona zeit hoffentlich ist es dann bis
weihnachten auch etwas besser geworden
natürlich wollte und sollte mal drücken
dann bleiben wir stark und der name
recht herzlich dass du dabei sagen
gestern der preis sein gedacht haben
vielen dank